اقل من نصف ساعه متبقيه على مغيب الشمس
هنا في مرصد تمير شمال العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض هذا المرصد ابراهيم هو واحد من عشر
مراصد في السعوديه معتمده لدى المحكمه
العليا يعتمد ربما كثيرا على هذا المرصد
وتتجه الانظار له نظرا لموعد غروب الشمس
مبكرا مقارنه ببقيه المراصد وعلى الرغم من
تقارب المواعيد الا ان هذا المرصد سيكون
من المراصد الاولى التي يغيب فيها التغيب
فيها الشمس هنا كما نشاهد في هذه الصوره
التلسكوب من مدينه الملك عبد العزيز
للعلوم والتقنيه بالاضافه الى المترائين
المنتدبين حكوميا والذين يعملون على رؤيه
هلال شهر رمضان
بالعين الم وتقديم الشهادات لمندوبي
المحكمه العليا سواء بتقديم الشهادات
لرؤيه الهلال او عدم رؤيه هلال رمضان هنا
نشاهد تقنيه جديده من وزاره العدل
السعوديه وهي تقنيه تربط جميع مراصد
السعوديه العشر بالمحكمه العليا عبر
الاتصال المرئي لتسريع عمليه تقديم
الشهادات برؤيه الهلال من عدمه وايضا لرفع
كفاءه العمل حول رصد الاهله هنا ايضا
التواجد في هذا المرصد يتواجد مترائين
عملوا في هذا المرصد لسنوات طويله ربما 15
عاما ومن خلال هذا المرصد سيتم الاعلان
يعني بشكل رسمي من قبل المترائين هنا
برؤيه الهلال من عدمه وتقديم الشهاده
للمحكمه العليا ثم ترفع من المحكمه العليا
الى الملك سلمان ويصدر البيان الرسمي سواء
بان يكون
غدا هو اول ايام شهر رمضان او هو المتمم
لشهر شعبان والخميس هو اول ايام شهر رمضان
المبارك